yeah good evening and thanks for joining
us tonight at five o'clock I'm Sasha
Loftis as the weather warms up more
people are getting out on the water May
is water safety month and the city of
Las Vegas fire and rescue is practicing
Swift water rescue training at Cowabunga
water parks 8 news now reporter Brian
will is live at Cowabunga Bay tonight
with more on how you can stay safe on
the water this summer Brian
yeah good afternoon Sasha and we're here
at Cowabunga Bay water park the general
manzwater Park joins me now Cade and
he's had some pretty interesting guests
here over the last month during water
saves in moncade who is that guest and
they were here training for some water
safety yeah you know we had some really
unique guests Clark County Fire and
First Responders we're here on site
doing some Swift water rescue training
and uh yeah we're super proud to be able
to host the those firefighters and First
Responders as they kind of brush up and
get trained on some water emergency
rescue techniques and you know how to
handle those situations when it comes to
anything that happens within the city
now looking forward to pool season now
that it's finally warm what are some
tips people should keep in mind when in
and around the water for safety you know
as it gets warmer here in Las Vegas
obviously as the temperatures get hotter
people start going out to all the pools
and all the Aquatic facilities and you
know as water safety month is in May
it's a good reminder as guests start to
go out into those pools and stuff to
remember a few things one always be
vigilant when you're supervising or a
guardian of somebody and they're in the
water be actively participating
monitoring them always have eyes on the
guest two make sure they wear a properly
fitted life jacket if they need to make
sure it's not too small but also not too
big and lastly I think it's really
important this one's easiest know your
limitations know the style and the body
of the type of water you're getting into
sometimes they're fast moving sometimes
they've got waves sometimes they're just
wading pools but know your limits and be
aware of those limits now what is stuff
we can look forward to in Memorial Day
weekend it's finally warm last time we
were here spring break it was a little
chilly what can we look forward to now
on the week ahead man 90 degrees and
more hopefully but obviously a ton of
fun over 25 different attractions just
at this park alone but we've got great
things coming up our Wild West
Summerfest in Summerlin actually at the
Canyon Park we've got tons of activation
DJs tons of events and of course tons of
Thrills and chills for everybody awesome
we're looking forward to it reporting at
Cowabunga Bay in Henderson Brian will
eight news now